all right john you're in charge of this
one guys the infinity stones
and the tva do they mean they're useless
what does become of the avengers
end game timeline and infinity war for
that matter
new rockstars has the answer today we're
going to check
out loki infinity stones explained
useless
or secretly powerful and before we hop
into this just remember to
hit the like and subscribe to this
channel with the notifications on to get
notified whenever one of our videos is
up and uh subscribe to new rockstars too
while you're at it
let's do this let's jump in
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and perhaps the most upsetting
reveal in loki episode one was that
loki's glorious purpose of the infinity
stones was
only worth its weight in paperweight i
love that moment
they were the crucial namesake of
marvel's entire infinity saga sought
after by thanos the avengers guardians
of the galaxy asgardians and sorcerers
black widow died and risked making her
long-awaited solo film less relevant ned
died for nothing
so did iron man and thanos black widow
gamora vision
sacred timeline loki heimdall and luke's
arm really
die for nothing if the tba has a drawer
full of duplicate infinity stones
sliding around
loose with the silverware no i am here
to tell you that these stones weren't
just to rattle loki's pride and
certainly not to make a joke out of the
infinity saga but
as key symbols explaining how the tva
operates in relationship with the rest
of the mcu the first episode of loki
does such a good job reverting loki's
character development to that villainous
pride and ambition
that defined him back in the first
avengers film like notice how
immediately after scooping the avengers
and escaping to mongolia the first thing
he does is to try to assert dominance to
these random villagers
i am loki have asgard and we've come so
far with this guy
burdened with glorious purpose these
same words this guy had just uttered to
nick fury when he arrived to steal the
tesseract i am loki
of asgard and i am burdened with
glorious purpose but by the end of this
episode that pride
is shattered when loki scrambles to
retrieve the tesseract only to realize
that in the tba
infinity stones are a dime a dozen oh
you have these
oh we actually got a lot of those yeah
some of the guys use them as paper
weights
some of them but notice how loki briefly
palms a time stone perhaps the stone he
was most eager to acquire
someday remember that and then loki
moves is this the greatest power in the
universe
and then b-15 rushes in and erases all
of these stones inside casey's evidence
card as loki gives up his glorious
purpose but not out of respect of the
tva's illogical laws but really out of
acceptance that the infinity stones are
not the key to his glorious future that
he thought they would be
even an infinity stone is useless here
the tva is formidable see that's the
thing is like that was the biggest
comment i remember seeing on pretty much
any of our loki episode one related
videos
you know making them useless and pulling
basically another ralph boner
i didn't even realize at the time that
uh b15
disintegrates the entire kart's worth of
them i feel like it's not all that hard
to draw the connection of this
simply means that the stones just don't
mean anything to the tva
specifically no if anything it's a
confirmation of the multiverse yeah
absolutely
because then yeah you have a different
pocket of the world where the stones are
super powerful and we saw that in
avengers end game and it's still
the timeline supposed to play out so it
still has that importance you know yeah
i don't think it's powerless i think
it's more to do with the fact that
it's kind of like you know what when a
certain animal is fighting in their own
territory they are the dominant one yeah
and within the tva the infinity stones
are not strong but in a different
territory
they are a complete massive universal
threat absolutely it's a good metaphor
as loki asks how did the tva get these
duplicate infinity stones by casey
saying we get a lot of these i think
he's saying they confiscated these from
past detained variants
like notice how the other items in the
drawer include a french medal of honor
and the most valuable baseball card in
the world
and u-92 theorized that the oklahoma
nexus event was someone trying to get
rich off oil so really i think the idea
is that infinity stones are just one of
many treasures that
others before loki have skewed from
their sacred timeline to try to obtain
now before the ancient ones seem to
indicate that only infinity stone
removal could create a branch timeline
but now according to miss minutes
something as simple as checking in late
to work could create a next event which
sounds nuts
and based on rich wrinkle martin it
sounds like individuals making the wrong
choice happens all the time with all
kinds of people and each time it happens
the time keepers sound the alarm
the tva swoops in they detain the
variant they prune the branch and they
erase that variant but i think that also
means they keep whatever
loot that variant was after and after
doing this countless times
duplicate infinity stones have piled up
but how can multiple infinity stones
exist in the same time and space
like by the look of it it looks like we
had five reality stones in there well
according to everything we had been told
about the infinity stones they seemed to
be these sacred constants that embodied
elemental aspects of the universe power
space reality soul time and mind
together they maintained the proper flow
of time so much so that the end game
directors had to clarify that when
thanos
used the stones to destroy the stones
the stones were in fact atomized
they were atomized guys they're out of
us
that also means that when the avengers
returned from the time heist with those
stolen infinity stones in the present
those stones were
duplicates existing simultaneously
with the atomized stone mist after
thanos's garden snap
so by that rule multiple stone variants
can co-exist
in a single place before too long those
variants are returned
see that is pretty fascinating that's
pretty fun because yeah i hadn't even
thought of that that you have two
sets of stones on just the main mcu
timeline you have yeah the
the stone dust yeah and then you know
whatever with their time travel
mechanics of okay if we go back and we
get the stones from different points
we're still having them in the future of
our own progress
yeah i hadn't even thought of it that
way but that actually makes a whole lot
of sense
yeah i agree awesome let's move on so
does that make the infinity stones
worthless
in the tva yes but outside the tva hell
no
because the tva exists outside the
sacred timeline it's in the null time
zone the end credits actually suggest it
could be in some in between space the
nine realms
everything that tva detains and brings
inside the tva
are variants of a prime equivalent
in the sacred timeline which goes on i'm
disturbed
so when the tva arrested loki variant
l1130
there still existed the original prime
loki
in the sacred timeline who went back
with thor to asgard and went through the
events of the dark world and ragnarok
and infinity war but the moment this
loki picked up the tesseract he
spawned a variant timeline of variants
loki a variant tesseract that didn't
steal the tesseract
originals still important those are
still there
so when a variant infinity stones branch
is pruned
the variant stone loses its power its
glow fades a bit but when the avengers
stole variant stones from the past
those stones kept their power because
those branches had not yet been pruned
by cat meanwhile each of the stones here
in the drawer were
variant duds from other previously
pruned branches but despite these being
duds those six
prime infinity stones remain in the
sacred timeline fully powered
waiting to be found and used by the
avengers and thanos in the history we've
seen and then inevitably atomized by
thanos so it's just multiple timelines
so
all of the sacrifices made by the
avengers made by thanos are still
every bit as meaningful and the effects
those stone use is left on the world
still every bit is consequential when
loki bemoans
even and infinity stone is useless here
he's really using the stone as a
metaphor for his own uselessness but
what mobius is trying to get at is
this tva confined powerlessness doesn't
erase the other loki in the sacred
timeline
the reason why he makes loki watch his
favorite highlights is because there are
lessons to be learned from that story so
the history of the infinity saga
is not being erased by loki it's
informing this next step and the way
that the tva has to find a new purpose
for infinity stones be it paperweights
or lining fish tanks despite not knowing
what fish are so
too must variant loki find a new
glorious purpose meanwhile let's
remember casey's words there
yeah some of the guys use them as paper
weights some of them yeah he's not just
making a joke there the end credits show
a mind stone being used as a paperweight
so that also makes us wonder what he
meant by
some of them did someone else go rogue
and use a variant infinity stone for
some other purpose in the past
theoretically
if you could track down one of these
variant stones source
branch and if that branch either wasn't
fully pruned or if it were able to get
reformed that stone might reactivate
and take it back to that branch so let's
keep in mind loki fiddling with that
time stone there now it sounded like it
clunked back down in the drawer
but if he might have slightly pocketed
it before b15 erased that cart the way
he pocketed mobius's time twister
so sneakily
by checking out our new loki inspired
merch options like the shirt
time by going to newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to new rockstars looking breakdowns
thanks for watching bye
that's a great theory if he is running
around with a time stone he might just
try to alter his reality just with that
stone alone
yeah just keep it in his pocket until he
finds the realm or variation
where it's active and then go to town
wow
that's a good call it sounds like such a
loki thing to do yeah and it's a good
long game because they've already got us
sitting here going oh
you know we're arguing about if the
stones are useless and whether or not
they're
tainting just the you know legacy of the
story when in actuality this could be a
really great you know sneaky plan or
something like that or
it could come in clutch some other way
but it totally sets you up for
not only a time stone but you never know
what else you might have swept from that
drawer you know
that's true yeah that's pretty this
exists
it's got my mind working all right well
guys leave your thoughts down below
what'd you think of this are you still
upset
do you still think that the timeline is
tainted or did eric vos's masterful
explanation
make sense to you either way hit that
like button remember to subscribe click
the notification bell to get updated
every time a video is out
last but not least let's do a
scuba steve europe i just want to say
what's up to you i hope you're doing
well
out in the east coast keeping it real
working with the people helping
lives get better i don't know what this
cadence or flow
is i wish that you were here so that i
could actually hear your voice man we've
never
actually spoken even though you sent me
lots of cool
stuff you've been one of our longest
running patrons
i want a voice message from you steve i
want to hear your new york accent i want
you to like
cuss me out or something like that or or
you know
other things that are stereotypical of
uh you know the part of the country that
you're in
anyway hope you're doing well and uh
we'll catch you next month
much love
[Music]
awesome